last week I had the pleasure of
returning to Ghana my parents birthplace
my visit was on behalf of the UK charity
Africans to launch their time to shine
campaign there's no question
Ghana's on the rise in the last year
alone leaders and dignitaries including
Prince Charles Angela Merkel president
macron and even US First Lady Melania
Trump have all flocked to the country
however this new boom hasn't reached the
northern part of the country where I
visited there I encountered families who
live on less than $2 a day and children
as young as five who were forced to work
just to be able to eat but what struck
me most was that with even all of these
obstacles these children are dedicated
to their education and prepared to do
whatever it takes to stay in school with
truancy levels and exclusion rates on
the rise here in the UK I believe a
cultural exchange program between kids
from Britain and those in poorer
countries would go a long way to fixing
some of our issues Britain ranks 22nd in
literacy and 27th in numeracy in OECD
countries perhaps it's time we learn
from Africa I was following your trip to
Ghana with great interest in and I
completely agree with you it's as a
fellow guards and fellow Ghanaian myself
and it's interesting to see that
actually Ghana spends more both as a
percentage of GDP yes and as a
percentage of governing expenditure on
education we do okay and this is a
country that until not long ago it was a
highly indebted poor country so while
Garner's story of coming out of that
situation becoming a middle-income
countries is laudable it's also
interesting to see how much education
has been prioritizing at a time when in
the UK we have failed generations of
children now and you know I've done I
used to be the education editor here
it's going was I've done a lot of
reporting on education one thing I found
in all countries that have successful
education systems whether that's Finland
whether that's Singapore last Japan yeah
the one thing they have in common is a
long-term strategic cross party
agreement on education policy in Britain
not only do we radically change our
education policy with every change of
government even
every education secretary you when
Michael Gove Nicky Morgan near them
would turn the system on its heads and
it causes such misery for teachers such
confusion for pupils and it's the it's
the absolute opposite of a long-term
strategic vision as to how we can give
young people what they need at a time
when the skills they need are changing
radically radically that's gonna be the
challenge for garner as it is here
because they now have a very rigorous
education system in fact I've got
friends who have moved to the UK from
garner and said that their children are
totally onto challenging the standards
here a lower the expectations are lower
than in Ghana but we all now need to
work out how we can bring our kids up to
speed for digital automated economy well
this was even this was what I was so
impressed by I was in like the poorest
villages you can imagine and yet there
was such a focus on stem I want to show
you a wonderful girl I met I've
nicknamed her Malala from Ghana take a
look my name is I'm a girl of 14 years
of age I came from a small village in
Sangamon and I wish to be a doctor in
future Messing you've been participating
in our girls education program how
important do you think education is for
girls and the kids over there genuinely
want to go to school yeah my kids
genuinely don't want to go to school and
a lot of kids are generally these kids
over there know and they're told from a
very early get-go all right even though
they gotta do the rest of their chores
around the house and all the stuff that
they do if they don't get an education
they've got absolutely no way bettering
themselves yeah whereas our kids can sit
at home and in very in some cases
throughout their whole
I'll have to lift a finger and they'll
get chicken out however is that we
almost cap
how clever our kids could get bring back
the grammar school an extraordinary life
one minute you're in the poorest part
it's you're in I I see the tables I
study the tables and I did quite a bit
of this on my radio show be careful what
you might wish for because Singapore
sadly has some of the highest instances
of youth emotional health mental health
issues because because their drill drill
drill we need to be somewhere in between
we don't need the laziness that not your
children but the British chill weather
and you they won't know what they've got
till it's gone to use their or
expression these lovely little kids they
are so grateful because they've not had
what we have taken for granted a decade
but we don't strip what he was probably
a 10 or 11 years old and I showed him
how the other half were living yeah and
from that day he came home he's at war
how about this how about myself will you
come in Trevor and I agree that we
shouldn't necessarily copy or emulate
everything that the most successful
countries according to the tables are
doing but the UK is currently $27 in the
world for math yeah and 22nd in the
world for the reading that's according
to the peas are in OECD study of 15 year
olds for more than 70 countries we are
yeah it's it's a real disgrace given our
girls given our reasons given our
history actually having much - how much
thing I I mean I I love I love what the
guy in math is brought into the table
today you can say that
I would just counsel against reducing
this again to more spending or the
government's got or where the other
grammar schools or not because the truth
is that actually what makes a difference
is not just money but also what families
do and you can have the children doing
cultural exchanges but I suspect that
people who are the most important here
will be the parents in Shanghai
the average math homework done across
the globe is about five hours a week in
Shanghai they do 14 hours a week in
South Korea they only do three but
family spend up to about 25 percent of
their income on a private tuition and
that's all a decision of the family so I
would say what this is telling us is
something about family life as much as
it is about government policies of dad
which is the interesting things about
Ghana it looked up which I thought which
really surprised me I I always associate
educational failure with you know
similarities on interestingly in Ghana
forty five percent of children do not
live in a household with two parents yet
they have this incredible you have to
add to that but it's not because of the
breakdown of the family most of the time
it's because of poverty so therefore
another parent is living somewhere else
to work in the city to send back so they
still have an influence on their
children and it's a matriarchal society
the women run the show yeah so they've
got something to teach us about how to
deal how the the Ghanaian system with
various incidents caused it yeah but I
think this is in a way also an example
of something sociologist talked about
which is that education it's not just
content that you give to children if in
a cultural context yeah and all the
countries that are most successful they
ground education in a contra cultural
context that is relevant to children and
I think there's some interesting there's
some interesting messages there about
why it is that minority children don't
do so well in countries like Britain and
in America because they are part of an
education system that is not necessarily
catering to their cultural needs it's
not offering them role models or people
they can relate
and the evidence shows that they don't
see now you take Ghana it's not about
being black it's not about having only
one parents at home Ghana they have both
but they are thriving and that's because
there have been leaders in Ghana who
have decided to try and shape Ghanaian
education so that it meets the needs of
Ghana in okay we've got pretty much to
the end of our time but before we go a
couple of things
it's never easy starting a new job
you've got to figure out your way around
the office learn everyone's names most
importantly find out where the coffee
machine is but it's made even harder
when people won't stop bringing up what
you used to do as my old friends a Nick
Clegg knows all too well here's what
happened when he was asked a question by
The Daily Telegraph's James crisp during
a press conference in his new role as
head of global policy and communications
for Facebook you currently work for
Facebook which a lot of people in
Brussels blame or take solace in the
idea but Facebook was responsible for
the brexit vote previously you work with
David Cameron and put him into
government and some people say on the
path towards for brexit referendum so my
question is do you ever worry but you
are a brexit enabler and secondly what
what exactly is with going rate for a
Deputy Prime Minister these days thank
you no I did more of that when he was
Deputy Prime no I think he's gotten a
little bit tougher with this new
Facebook paycheck isn't it it's kind of
the week we've been talking about
children and it's a special day for one
of our younger panelists during this
recording Nick Ferrari yeah has turned
60 well exactly
I know when I cut into it Greg Dyke pops
are you feeling I'm looking forward to
the next 60 years wait till you get to
mind these are killing you thank you
very much for this week's program but
you're enjoying the debate by searching
for the pledge on Facebook or Twitter
see you next time
[Music]